and it is my pleasure to welcome usc
head basketball coach andy enfield to
the show coach how are you
doing very well thank you well i can
imagine congratulations on getting back
to the sweet 16 once again my friend
what an impressive performance
uh by you guys last night against kansas
you beat them by
34 points that never lost by more than
18
in the tournament taken down one of the
uh true blue bloods
of college basketball at what point did
you know you guys really had it going
well kansas is never out of a game
they're so good defensively
all season they're explosive offensively
and they've been playing great
basketball i think they won 9 out of 10
coming into the game and so they were
playing their best basketball at the end
of the year and their big center
mccormick was playing great and their
guards are so talented so
uh to be honest uh we we never thought
we had the game uh
until maybe about six or seven minutes
left when it ballooned up to
25 or 30 points but uh even at half time
we're up 19
and they came out made a quick run i had
to call time out about 17 minutes left
and
settle our guys down to just remind them
that uh this this game's not over
what was it eight years ago you made the
sweet 16 of florida gulf coast
yeah eight years ago yes it was a
special run
uh by fgcu the eagles what great players
we had was a lot of fun
how how does this feel different or does
it
well it's totally different uh i was
there two years
we were a brand new school brand new
program uh we just had
the school just gone division one uh in
the way that those players came together
and the
the exciting style of play they had this
is different because uh
our coaching staff came in here eight
years ago and built this program and
jason hart my associate head coach chris
capco curtis schultz they've been with
me
the entire time and so to see uh
being last place in the pac-12 for two
years our first two years were five and
31 in the pac-12
uh and we weren't we just weren't very
good and we were able to recruit and
develop some players and have
some success here the last six years and
so
this is a great game to uh for our
program
to to show how far the usc program has
come so
uh it was a little different feeling
that than the florida gulf coast uh run
but uh at the same time any time you can
go to the sweet 16
it's just special for the players and so
i i i'm
i'm really happy for our players right
now because they work so hard to get
here
you talked about some of your assistant
coaches uh eric mobley and
jason hart and chris capco and coach
desmond which one of those guys
was it that brought your attention to to
cbs saying you guys were undisciplined
well we were at lunch and coach mobley
pulled his phone out to watch a game or
check on
some scores from the tournament this in
the afternoon we played the late game so
he literally turned his phone on turned
the cbs and
and it broke to a studio show and
and uh i don't even know who said it uh
we just heard it
we saw it and heard it and uh just said
we were undisciplined and they were
picking kansas so
look everybody has an opinion uh we were
just fortunate to play well last night
and
at least play good basketball yeah well
i i i love
everybody has to find a chip right
everybody has to have something to hold
on their shoulder tom brady does it uh
more so than anybody and he's the
greatest quarterback in nfl history
did you use that guy did you use that as
fuel did you talk to your team about
that
no we didn't talk to the team we our
staff heard it so our staff was uh
we were just a little uh it made us very
angry because uh if you looked at the
ken palm numbers
which shows defensive and offensive
efficiency right we're ranked fifth in
the nation defense in the top
20 in offense and i think our overall
ken palm right now is sixth in the
nation so
uh you know that it was just uh an
uncalled for comment uh for someone who
probably had never seen us play
well i i thought you handled it well it
was probably barkley just blaming on
barkley
barkley's great i love charles barkley
yeah he's the best so i know
definitely wasn't him he's great well
let me ask you about
the mobley family has been pretty good
for you uh you got a coach on your staff
you got
you know evan who's going to be a top
five pick he's been nothing short of
spectacular
uh but big bro isaiah has been really
really good for you guys in the
tournament well the whole mobley family
is special uh
from nicole the mother she was there
with her some of her relatives and
coach mobley eric has done a great job
he's been on our staff for three years
isaiah came two years ago in evan of
course this year
but uh evan and isaiah have improved so
much as players
uh but the greatest thing i can say
about those guys they're just winners
that they they're
they don't have an ego they're they just
play team basketball and
and uh we're a team uh isaiah and evan
are playing well but so are all the
other guys
and and they're the first two guys to
give their teammates credit and they
know they wouldn't be here without the
rest of the team
and so it's great to see evan and isaiah
improve so much and
and take the leadership but uh we we're
really playing well as a team right now
this is this is where you want to be as
a coach you you leave florida gulf coast
you come to los angeles i think we live
in the
the same general uh vicinity and you
make the trek every day up to
usc um and it's obviously it's well
known
usc is a football school i i went to a
tennessee it's a football school
that's produced some really good
basketball teams over the years but one
of the hard things at usc is being
consistently good year in and year out
in basketball do you think this is the
step in the right direction for you guys
to be able to do that obviously you've
had success since you've been here
but the first sweet 16 for the school
since 07.
yeah we we uh we understand the
difficulty look i was at florida state
as an assistant coach for five years
with leonard hamilton that's a football
school as well
uh i love football my wife amanda loves
college football so
we really root for the trojans and and
their football program
and i think when they do well it helps
the entire school it helps the
the national brand but at the same time
it doesn't help you win basketball games
because you have a good football team
you have to go
do that on your own and so i i think um
uh what really uh has been difficult or
was difficult when we first took the job
was just the lack of sustained success
in the usc basketball program over the
history of it because
there's been some great coaches and
players over it and great teams
but the lack of sustained success or the
tradition so when you go play a kansas
that
has had decades and decades of that
tradition and the sustained success
it's a whole different type of program
and and fan support so uh
we we're doing our best to try to
sustain that success we
last six years i think we're 14th or
15th in the country and wins among the
power five conferences i think we have
133 wins
last two years we're 46 and 16 which is
third in the nation and wins
among the six power conferences behind
baylor and kansas so
for usc to be 46 and 16 the last two
years that's a credit to our players
they've just done a terrific job
it's been a minute for you guys since
you were in the elite eight uh i think
it was brian scalibrini's team back in
in 2000 2001-ish have you heard from
anybody from
from that team who's rooting for you
guys to get back there
i get some texts i know our assistant
coaches desmond farmer who played on the
elite team he's a graduate assistant for
us now uh
uh so so he gets a lot of he knows those
guys because he was on that team
i just got a call from a mo layton today
who who is is a legend in usc hoops he
played with west wall uh
before paul i guess in the same team and
and mo leighton
was really one of the guys that started
some of that success so
it is nice to hear from the ex trojans i
i've had some ex coaches
reach out to me and so so that that's
really nice i think everyone's rooting
for our players we got a special team
this year
yeah it's been a fun team to watch i've
had the opportunity to watch you guys a
little bit like i said uh
being in the area the the move to to la
from from florida gulf coast for you
have there been any uh moments when you
look up in the stands at a game or
you're sitting there at the manhattan
country club watching maria sharapova
play tennis and
you're saying man this you're seeing a
star-studded
person that you may not have expected to
see on that particular day give me one
of those la moments
well i i'd probably say it's uh when i
go to the beach
and i see the the olympic beach
volleyball players and they're like wow
they're a lot better athlete than i ever
was whoever will be so uh
but but uh you know you do see uh
the southern california the los angeles
area is a great place to live uh we we
love the
the lifestyle of my wife and our family
and and uh
and we just have a lot of friends that
in the entertainment the sports business
and just uh people that are we've met
along the way they're just terrific
families so uh we really enjoy the area
all right last question coach before we
let you go you got oregon coming up
you're gonna play them again you played
them during the regular season you guys
won that game
um i've heard your quote hey you know
we'd rather not play organ
a conference team that we've played
before we'd rather play somebody out of
the pac-12 but
the good news is that no matter what
happens in this game it'll be a pac-12
team in the elite eight
you don't you don't really mean that you
don't care if oregon go see the lead
eight
you want to get in the elite right i
mean it sounds good in theory
well of course we would like to win that
game but i i i was
just confused of how oregon our two
league teams can play each other in the
sweet 16. so i was
confused on how that happens i'm not i
don't know what this
the selection committee or the criteria
how they see teams or what brackets they
put them in so
i apologize i just don't know enough
information to comment on that but
oregon has a tremendous team and
i the reason i said what i said
yesterday was
i think it is unfortunate for the pac-12
for us to have to play oregon because
we're first since the oregon was first
we were second in the league
and to have the first and second teams
play in the sweet 16 is not ideal
because the march madness is all about
playing teams from other conferences and
playing teams that you've never played
before or or haven't played in a while
so
it'll be a it'll be a heck of a game uh
two good teams going at it from the same
league and
we'll do our best speaking of the league
i lied i have one more question the
pac-12 has been
so good i i mean surprisingly good in
this tournament
um did that surprise you that you guys
got four teams into the sweet 16 i think
it's surprising but
uh it's not surprising in the fact that
we have a really good league
and the teams we've been the teams in
our league
obviously can beat anybody else in the
country on a given night and you've seen
that we're nine and one and eleven
four in the sweet sixteen so i i think
if you would have said hey four out of
five teams are going to go the sweet 16
i think a lot of people would be
surprised me included but but but
pleasantly surprised but i'm not
surprised at the level of play because
we've been battling these teams all year
long
and we've been trying to tell the media
you know i'm from the east coast
so i never saw a ufc basketball game
growing up i saw usc football on
saturday afternoon
i loved the cardinal gold jerseys and
that was my favorite football uniform
but that was because it was on sunday
afternoons i never saw a usc basketball
game on the east coast because the game
started seven or eight o'clock and you
just don't follow the pac-12 so
i think the pac-12 is not appreciated
enough on a national scale just because
of the time difference
and the uh and the lack of exposure to
the east coast into the midwest so
uh our league was really good last year
we had six teams in the tournament last
year as well we put 10 draft picks in
the nba last year and so
and now you're seeing some really good
basketball teams advance and i'm happy
for our league
back in the sweet 16 is usc for the
first time since 07
trying to get to the elite eight for the
first time since 2001
andy enfield congratulations andy it's
been fun to watch you guys play it
really is a fun team you guys are
playing some lockdown defense you're
shooting the three ball
uh good luck the rest of the way thank
you very much hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here